moi avant j'étais j'étais étudiant aussi
et franchement j'ai galéré aussi pendant
mes études et maintenant que je suis élu
j'ai pas le pouvoir de changer les
choses parce que Macron et Le Pen ils
arrêtent pas de s'allier contre les
étudiants mais j'essaie quand même de
faire monter enfin de continuer de
défendre quoi une question comment tu as
fait pour te présenter et C ENF c'est
comment je sais pas c'est quoi les
démarches que tu fait en fait j'ai été
candidat pour la France insoumise après
ensuite il y a eu l'alliance de tout le
monde et donc du coup tout le monde
s'est allié et j'ai été élu comme ça
mais ça a été un enchaînement de
circonstances vraiment bizarre parce que
être élu à 21 ans quand on a juste le
bac et 10 en plus c'est j'étais le
premier
[Musique]
choqué
hop bonjour je suis le député Louis
Boyard député de la 3e circonscription
du valde Marne et on est à viletaneuse
pour parler de précarité étudiante un
sujet que j'essaie de faire monter sur
lequel j'essaie d'obtenir des victoires
depuis quelques mois à l'Assemblée
nationale donc on va aller rencontrer
les étudiants et parler de leur galère
du quotidien
de Montpellier 3 à Renn 2 de Bordeau
Montaigne à mien Picardie Louis Boyard
écume les universités de France depuis
son élection il est aujourd'hui sur un
campus de scè sa-denis où l'union
étudiante un syndicat de gauche organise
une distribution
alimentaire vous avez quoi du
coup des
concombres vous avez trouvé où tout ça
V du CROUS ok trop bien wou vous avez
même des
amendes ça ça va partir en 30 secondes
non vraiment moi j'adore ça heureusement
que vous êtes là vraiment et c'est quoi
qui demande le plus en général les
étudiants c'est quoi le plus difficile
pour eux à se fournir les fruits et les
légumes par exemple c'est quelque chose
qui aide beaucoup les étudiants parce
que c'est quelque chose qui pèse dans
leur et pareil pour les conserves en
fait les produits type amande cookies
faire des choses qui font plaisir et qui
coûtent cher ouais VO ok parce que
raffiné ce qui a pas été épargné par
l'inflation aussi c'est les produits
d'hygienne c'est compliqué d'acheter du
savon c'est de plus en plus cher là on a
quand même essayé de faire un truc un
peu sympa avec des produits
bio vous avez des étudiants qui ont des
parents qui peuvent leur donner de
l'argent pour pouvoir survivre et encore
la plupart des étudiants qui sont aidés
par leurs parents ils vivent toujours
sous le seil de pauvreté et vous avez
ceux qui n'ont pas d'aide et quand vous
prenez cette masse d'étudiants là en
fait vous découvrez l'océan carité
étudiante qu'on vit actuellement en
France quand vous allez à l'université
vous vivez avec 300 400 € par mois vous
devez payer le loyer la nourriture les
fournitures scolaires les transports
c'est invivable et il y en a beaucoup
qui craquent tout simplement et qui du
coup arrêtent leurs études et après on
leur dit vous êtes responsable de votre
situation non c'est pas vrai c'est
aujourd'hui il y a une inégalité qui est
flagrante à l'université et la
distribution alimentaire ça en est le
plus grand
symbole la précarité étudiante est une
réalité chiffrée en France un jeune sur
4 vit sous le seuil de pauvreté et les
étudiants ne sont pas épargnés ils sont
36 % à sauter régulièrement à repas
selon une étude de l'association COP 1
le travail de terrain de Louis Boyard
consiste à mettre des visage sur ces
chiffres comme avec cet étudiant
fraîchement arrivé d'Anger moi je suis
venu Mo j'aV pas pensé mais un oreiller
une couette avait pas oui les trucs de
base de be mais j'avais pas tout
ça surpris ouais après la Navigo FO je
vis juste acheter des céréales les
céréalesû chers le matin je je mange pas
le matin les pâesange tous les jours des
pâtes tous les jours même en vrai de la
viande j'ai pas de viande là je peux
plus ouais et le gouvernement tu as
l'impression qu'il fil un coup de main
ou pas le pousse à un€ comme je suis
boursé en vrai ça m' vraiment ça ouais
mais tu peux l'avoir le soir le soir bah
non il y a pas dans mon secteur de ouver
le soir alors moi à l'Assemblée j'ai
proposé un revenu étudiant tu en penses
quoi un revenu étudiant ouais en vrai ça
M beaucoup pour mes
études pour pour vivre même des fois
parce je faire des sorties ça mais je
peux pas les faire Louis Boyard milite
pour une allocation d'autonomie qui
permet à chaque étudiant de bénéficier
d'au moins 112 € par mois le député a
déposé l'année dernière une proposition
de loi dans ce sens mais elle n'a pas
été débattue dans l'hémicycle la
principale barrière que nous on a à
l'Assemblée nationale pour faire
reconnaître un revenu étudiant c'est que
à chaque fois qu'on dit mais en fait si
vous voulez que tous les étudiants il
puissent étudier à égalité vivre
audessus du seuil de pauvreté faut
arrêter avec votre système de bourse
faut arrêter d'encourager le salarié
étudiant il faut un revenu étudiant quoi
ça existe déjà dans d'autres pays et à
chaque fois ce qu'on nous répond c'est
salariat étudiant bourse salariat
étudiant bourse et en fait quand on
parle aux étudiants on se rend compte
que c'est une très mauvaise solution ça
les handicapes plus qu'autre chose un
job étudiant dans les études ça plombe
quoi c'est la première cause d'échec en
licence alors que le député est là pour
nous parler de précarité une demande
inattendue lui tombe
dessus dans dans l'amphi ah vous voulez
que j'aille dans l'amphi parler du
Parlement parce que prof elle est pas
encore là pour le moment donc pour bah
ouais mais la prof ouais mais est-ce que
la prof elle va être d'accord c'est ça
aussi c'est vrai on l' pas demandé bon
ben on y va allez go
allez tu peux me prendre mon sandwich
parce que je va pas faire cour avec un
sandwich coton dans les mains il
se ah est là elle vient d'arriver moi du
coup j'étais juste venu pour parler de
distribution alimentaire mais les
étudiants du coup ils sont venus me voir
ils m'ont ditou il a déà TR qu on St
voilà moi j'ai dit je je vais pas faire
le cours donc alors j'ai 2h de de cours
sur le Conseil constitutionnel à faire
et déjà 10 minutes de retard mais je
vous laisse uncard ok pas de souci avec
grand
plaisir et voilà comment le député se
transforme tout d'un coup en maître de
conférence bah bonjour Merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup de bah de me laisser
venir ici parler en fait de base c'était
pas du tout prévu et c'est parti pour
une mastercl totalement
improvisée aujourd'hui Macron euh et sa
première ministre borne ils ont pas 289
députés ils ont pas la majorité donc du
coup pour faire passer une loi c'est la
galère est-ce que d'après toi euh une
modification de la Constitution ce
serait bien ou mal on peut modifier la
Constitution avec l'article 11
c'est-à-dire Macron il arrive et il dit
bon ben on va faire un changement dans
la Constitution c'est pas tout à fait
constitutionnel ça quandême bah
l'article 11 où il peut modifier la
Constitution aussi c'est ce quile pas
quel article pour modifier la
Constitution
moi j'ai pas terminé mes études de droit
donc non l'article 11 c'est le
référendum c'est le référendum
législatif et en tout cas on fera
l'Assemblée constituante si jamais notre
programme est appliqué bon faut que
j'aille à la distribution alimentaire
voilà bah c'était chouette
[Applaudissements]
bisous j' faire des références à votre
intervention au semestre ok pas de souci
bon courage pour le couré merci c'est
bien parce qu'ils sont intéressés aux
questions de 6e République de 393 de
tout ce qui se passe en fait autour de
l'Assemblée nationale et de la
démocratie aujourd'hui en France donc
c'it ultra intéressant c'était chouette
comme échange et puis bon bah c'est
chouette de parler d'autres choses que
de précarité étudiante parce que tous
les sujets les
intéressent passer cette parenthèse
Louis Boyard retourne à son combat pour
les étudiants il est cette fois au
campus pyramide de créteille toujours
avec un représentant syndical il y a un
an il s'était rendu dans cette fac pour
dénoncer des conditions d'étude
délétaire
un autre volet de la précarité étudiante
il revient sur les lieux pour voir si la
situation a évolué si le plafond n'a pas
été
réparé on a ce genre de ventilation un
peu partout sur les étages et c'est
complètement dégradé et voilà ça tombe
assez souvent on les retrouve par terre
et donc c'est à nous de les remettre et
pu voilà c'est pareil de juste de
l'autre côté du mur aussi alors là aussi
il y a des travaux et donc le sol il est
pas
adapté là c'est les toilettes où il y a
pas de Lavo là c'est des toilettes même
pas les main ah oui il y a vraiment il y
a pas de lavabo quoi y a pas de lav ils
ont quand même été sympas ils ont mis du
savon mais ils ont oublié les lavabau
enfin il y a quand même des endroits ici
où les garçons sont obligés d'aller dans
les toilettes des filles quoi dans une
université française et aussi je sais
pas si ça va s'entendre dans la vidéo
mais il y a des travaux et donc là il il
y a qu actuellement les étudiants il
sont travailler dans ces conditions là
on porte des doudounes là parce que j'ai
un il fait très froid en fait ce n'est
pas isolé là l'hiver il a même pas
vraiment commencer on cumule le froid le
fait qu'il y a pas de la vabo que dans
certaines étages il y a pas d'au la
peinture qui est faite que sur un mur
les faux plafonds qui s'effondrent les
travaux au sol le bruit le manque
d'information c'est c'est tout ça qui
fait que en fait vous êtes pas
respecté les syndicats étudiants de
créteille sont mobilisés depuis
plusieurs mois pour obtenir des avancées
le genre de combat que le député ancien
représentant lycéen puis étudiant
connaît par cœur il profite donc de sa
visite bonjour pour donner quelques
conseils au délégués de l'UNEF salut la
rectrice nous a reçu on a fait une
mobilisation quelques semaines on a pu
tout lui dire sur le campus pyramide sur
le cru sur tout ce qu'on avait à dire
déjà vous avez réussi à avoir à ramener
la rectrice bon elle est sortie de son
bureau elle a fait 100 m elle est venue
vous voir comment est-ce que vous avez
fait pour la faire venir on a lancé une
mobilisation avec les étudiants aussi
les personnels et les professeurs une
manifestation qui partait de base à la
dalle on a réussi à la décaler jusque
devant le rectorat on a fait du bruit on
l'a fait sortir ok trop bien en vrai
vous montrez une chose c'est que même si
jamais vous avez pas encore gagné mais
je sais que vous finirez par gagner la
mobilisation elle paye tout est une
question de rapport de force la lutte
paye ce que je recommande toujours de
faire commencer par une assemblée
générale parce que c'est le moment où
vous avez tous les jeunes qui se
retrouvent ensemble dans la même pièce
et une fois qu'ils ont commencé à
s'organiser en nombre c'est là où il
faut commencer à faire du bruit et pour
faire du bruit il faut être visible donc
donc faites des vidéos faites des
manifestations montrez-vous alertez les
gens dites regardez ce qui se passe
c'est pas normal il y a rien que le
gouvernement et les haut fonctionnaires
détestent plus que d'avoir l'opinion
publique qui se monte contre eux et
ensuite une fois que vous avez informé
tout le monde là vous commencez le bras
de fer et pour donner un dernier coup de
main à la lutte avant de repartir la
visite va se terminer par un
incontournable de la méthode
boyardinquiète pas de lavabo des des
faux plafonds qui tombent le fait qu'il
fasse froid et bref personne qui répond
alors là je repose une vidéo destinée
aux réseaux sociaux l'autre grand
terrain de lutte du
député regardez jusqu'où doivent aller
les étudiants pour se faire entendre CIS
pas il y a personne au lycée Christophe
Colomb avec
584000 abonnés sur TikTok et 105000 sur
Instagram il est l'un des députés les
plus suivis sur les smartphones c'est à
l'Assemblée dans son bureau que Louis
Boyard et son équipe concoctent ses
vidéos souvent percutant
tout se joue au montage le secret bien
connaître les codes des réseaux sociaux
l'enjeu toucher un public jeune qui ne
s'intéresse pas toujours à la politique
c'est très très bien on balancer à 18h
let's
go des changements de plan très
dynamique des plans progressifs beaucoup
de cut tout le temps des S très courts à
chaque fois pour que le mot soit plus
court possible pour que toujours l'œil
soit soit dynamique là il y a la
rectrice qui est à 100 m alors parfois
on est caricaturé on est on est moqué
moi il y a certaines personnes qui
m'appellent députés TikTok mais en soit
j'en ai pas honte du tout je suis fier
justement de porter la culture de
internet de ma génération à l'Assemblée
nationale et les jeunes ils attendent ça
et là vous regardez un petit peu même le
gouvernement commence à s'y mettre he
Elizabeth borne elle aussi elle commence
à faire la même chose pourquoi parce
qu'ils comprennent que aujourd'hui c'est
c'est cette nouvelle manière de
communiquer en politique donc ils
peuvent dire ce qu'ils veulent mais ils
critiquent mais ils cliquent influenceur
lanceur d'alerte meneur de lutte Louis
Boyard est très actif dans les fac
devant son écran mais qu'en est-il de
son travail à l'Assemblée député de
l'opposition il s'est illustré par des
prises de parole incisive face au fil
d'étudiants devant les distributions
alimentaires pourquoi l'action du
gouvernement est-elle aussi pauvre qu'un
sandwich du cru mais pour l'instant il
n'a pas obtenu de victoire législative
significative quand on a des moments où
je peux utiliser le travail législatif
pour essayer de gagner des choses ça
tombe ça tombe à l'eau à cause du 493 et
quand je doit m'appuyer sur d'autres
textes pour essayer de gagner des choses
bah ces textes ils apparaissent pas
parce que aujourd'hui le Parlement ne
débat pas de précarité étudiante alors
puisque je sais que sur ce combat là à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est perdu
d'avance je vais mener le combat dans la
société et je vais convaincre d'autres
personnes et ces personnes elles font
pression sur le gouvernement et si ça ne
fonctionne pas et ben elles voteront
pour nous et là ensuite on le mettra en
place le groupe parlementaire de la
France insouise prépare une nouvelle
proposition de loi qui concerne les
étudiants elle vise à répondre à la
crise du logement chez les jeunes
notamment en augmentant les APL Louis
Boyard et signataire le texte pourrait
être étudié dans les prochains
[Musique]
mois